no livro de álbuns ramsley admirável
mundo novo
nos traz uma sociedade futura baseado em
seres humanos geneticamente modificados
e em castas hierarquicamente rígidas
essas casas são compostas por pessoas
fertilizados in vitro não havendo mais
os papéis de pai e mãe
as crianças são cuidadas pelo estado ea
de estradas para viverem conforme suas
cascas de y metas e as pessoas são
sempre alegres e felizes por meio da
pílula soma inventada por rankings lei
tem suas tristezas e frustrações
bloqueadas
essa sociedade asséptica de rankings lei
composta por pessoas sempre dedicadas e
condicionadas a viverem de acordo com
uma suposta mais social ocs lei a
descreveu em 1932
hoje passados 82 anos
ela nos faz pensar sobre o que a
sociedade nós estamos querendo viver
será que queremos que os avanços da
biotecnologia nos conduzam ao admirável
mundo novo
é inegável o avanço da biotecnologia nos
últimos séculos
podemos dar aqui um extenso elenco de
exemplos tais como vacinas biofármacos
testes preditivos manipulação genética
de embriões transplante de órgãos
medicamentos de novíssimas gerações
enfim o elenco aqui a gente tenha a
gente pode né falar sobre vários avanços
da biotecnologia entretanto esses
avanços eles vieram acompanhados da
sociedade de consumo tornando-se
um importante nicho mercadológico na
expressão cunhada pelo filósofo
norte-americano nozick a expressão
supermercado genético
nós já podemos encontrar 20% dos genes
humanos já se encontram patenteados
pelas empresas de biotecnologia estão
considerando a sociedade de consumo e o
supermercado genético
nós devemos parar e pensar sobre os
limites ecos dos avanços da
biotecnologia aplicadas aos seres
humanos
será que nós devemos fazer tudo aquilo
que podemos fazer bem pra gente falar
sobre esses limites éticos vamos dar
dois exemplos sobre os avanços da
biotecnologia aplicados aos seres
humanos
o primeiro exemplo diz respeito aos
medicamentos que interferem nos
sentimentos e humores humanos tais como
os antidepressivos e semelhantes
independentemente de reconhecer a
eficácia desses medicamentos é
importante a gente parar e refletir
sobre o fenômeno da medicalização da
vida ou da sua super medicalização nós
estamos transformando a tristeza o luto
a perda a solidão em doenças e estamos
nos tornando incapazes de lidar com
esses elementos afetivos essenciais e
que enriquecem a nossa vida
no mesmo sentido o médico italiano
marcos bobbio me chama atenção para o
alargamento do diagnóstico do transtorno
de déficit de atenção e hiperatividade
nós presenciamos neste momento um
elevado número de crianças que vêm sendo
diagnosticadas com esse transtorno
tanto no brasil quanto no mundo e aí
esses exemplos eles nos fazem pensar
será que nós não estamos buscando uma
pílula soma que nos torna sempre alegres
felizes socialmente ajustados
tal como descrito por rancho em um
admirável mundo novo
bem o outro exemplo diz respeito à
manipulação genética de embriões hoje na
fertilização in vitro
já é possível manipular esses embriões
os chamados bebês de encomenda o que
mais uma vez nos leva ao admirável mundo
novo
esses bebês ou esses embriões
manipulados geneticamente na verdade
eles são pré determinados pelos seus
manipuladores para se tornarem aquilo
conforme o desejo deles será que é ético
criar filhos como a cor dos olhos a cor
da pele o sexo e talvez no futuro com
traços de personalidade geneticamente
pré determinados
bem eu não sei o que vocês pensam sobre
isso mas eu creio que as crianças
geneticamente manipuladas dessa forma
na verdade elas são instrumentalizados
pelos seus manipuladores e pelos seus
genitores os avanços da biotecnologia
aplicadas aos seres humanos eles são um
fato mas a possibilidade de fazermos
algo não significa que nós enquanto
sociedade devemos fazer e se esses
avanços porém apenas guiados pelos
interesses mercadológicos podemos estar
diante no futuro não muito distante de
um estágio pós humano com seres humanos
da nossa espécie mais distinto de nós
talvez seres humanos mais felizes sim
talvez seres humanos ajustado
socialmente e talvez seres humanos com
uma memória incapaz de esquecer isso nos
conduz a pensar o que nos faz humanos
será que o que faz um do que o que nos
faz humanos é apenas o nosso hub pedir
smo a quantidade de conexões cerebrais o
nosso código genético
bem nós iremos destacar aqui três pontos
cruciais para entender o que nos faz
humanos que a busca pelo reconhecimento
a empatia ea memória
o ser humano
desde que nasci ele busca pelo
reconhecimento do outro e constrói a sua
identidade a partir do reconhecimento do
outro no decorrer da sua vida o bebê
quando ele é amamentado pela mãe ele
busca o olhar da mãe a criança busca o
olhar dos pais o adolescente o olhar dos
colegas de escola
os adultos dos colegas de trabalho do
chefe dos parceiros nós humanos buscamos
incessantemente o olhar do outro e
construímos a nossa identidade
a nossa biografia a partir desse olhar e
o reconhecimento está ligado a empatia
que é a capacidade que nós temos de nos
importar com o outro então a empatia e o
reconhecimento eles estão entrelaçados o
reconhecimento então ele valoriza o
outro ele reconhece o valor do outro
como ser semelhante ao meu mas legítima
concomitantemente às suas diferenças ea
empatia a empatia é dar a mão a alguém
que se encontra no fundo do poço
a simpatia não é apenas solidariedade
a empatia é o movimento afetivo na
direção do outro
a empatia eo reconhecimento estão
interligados por quê
e aí eu vou falar pra vocês sobre o
grande paradoxo humano que é o seguinte
nós só nos tornamos nós mesmos por meio
do outro e o terceiro elemento é a
memória
nós construímos a nossa história de vida
a partir da memória das experiências que
temos dessa história a nossa memória é
constituída por cheiros sentimentos
desejos afectos percepções daquilo que
vivemos duas pessoas podem vivenciar o
mesmo fato
mas as suas memórias sobre aquele fato
são completamente distintas
então as nossas memórias conferem 5
idade ao que nós somos e essas memórias
que nós temos
elas vão variando mudamos no decorrer do
tempo a memória que vocês tinham quando
adolescente da sua infância da infância
de vocês não é a mesma memória que vocês
têm na vida adulta porque nós vamos
resignar ficando as nossas memórias
a partir da experiência que nós vamos
tendo na vida bem voltando ao admirável
mundo novo de ram clay pessoas sem
apegos afetivos sem sentimentos de
solidariedade e presas a castas
hierarquicamente fixas são consideradas
da espécie humana
diante disso eu creio que nós estamos no
momento
no momento propício para pararmos de
pensar sobre os limites éticos dos
avanços da biotecnologia quando
aplicadas aos seres humanos
e pensar que nem tudo aquilo que nós
podemos fazer nós devemos fazer e essa
decisão ela tem que ser eticamente
refletida e também descobrir que ser
humano também e ser triste
a tristeza o luto a frustração são
experiências únicas do humano que ser
editado ou inquieto não é
necessariamente uma doença e que ser
humano também é essencialmente conviver
olhar para o outro
bem eu não sei aqui o que cada um de
vocês está fazendo com a sua própria
vida ou como olha para o outro como
reconhece ou como exerce a sua empatia
mas eu sei que é hora de pararmos de
pensar pra pensar que a sociedade nós
estamos querendo construir que sociedade
nós estamos construindo para nós mesmos
e que sociedade nós queremos deixar para
as futuras gerações
obrigada